as far as
language and these uh systems they
really like ufos you hear about them you
never see them every time i try one of
them
it doesn't know i i don't want to be
it's too early to speak french
there's no we keep saying that they're
doing well where
come on wallid sabo is a polymath a
neuroscientist
a psychologist a linguist a philosopher
a statistician and a logician one of the
arguments that he makes
vociferously online is that natural
language processing
is not the same as natural language
understanding
i lived the the transition from
the gophi the good old-fashioned ai
into empirical ai you should definitely
check out wally subber's medium page
i've taken the time to read all of it
it's an absolutely fantastic
collection of information and the first
one to look at is his most recent
article which is time to put an
end to bertology he believes that
machine learning is
not relevant to natural language
understanding and in here
he makes three core arguments so the
first one is this missing text
phenomenon
and he thinks that most of the time when
we communicate we're extremely ambiguous
and the important information is simply
not in
the data if you ask any deep learning
practitioners
what do you think are the core
challenges in deep learning they will
answer you
one sample efficiency problem two
the generalization problem according to
walled suburb he thinks
the missing information problem is the
biggest one there are ten
big problems in language computational
english give them labels like
metonymy lexicon beauty metaphor
all these big problems in language and
they're all a manifestation of the
missing text
so he gives an example of the missing
information problem here is anna do
quick graduate school to join a software
company
we have an ontological structure in our
brains
we can fill in the gaps so we can create
data where none was transmitted
so we know that xanadu is a living young
human adult and was in graduate school
but quit
graduate school to join a software
company that had a need for a new
employee so we filled in
a lot of information there and wallet
gives many examples
these are the biggest domains in natural
language understanding
where there is pervasive missing
information
and humans can fill in the missing
information because we have that
ontological structure in our brains
walid then provides what he believes is
a proof that machine learning
cannot perform natural language
understanding he says that machine
learning is equivalent to compression
that natural language understanding is
not compression it's expansion
and therefore natural language
understanding is not machine learning
what we have that's missing are not
rules ironically they are data
but different kinds of data it's the
data we don't say
so it's like data plus data will do the
trick
he also talks about this concept of
intention spelt with an s
now this is really important in logic
because most of us
programmers and people that have done
empirical science
we think that two things are equal only
if they share the same value
but intention means that they are equal
if they share all of the same properties
so there are some examples here of some
mathematical constructions
which have the same output but clearly
the
properties or the construction is
different so logically these things are
different
which means they have a different
intention they have the same extension
but they have a different intention and
in natural language understanding there
are almost
zero degrees of freedom the intention is
very important
and this is something that wallet points
out a lot in many of his examples
so for example mary taught her little
brother that seven plus nine equals 16
and also 7 plus 9 equals the square root
of 256
those two are different it also points
out there are many examples in natural
language where
statistics don't work because words
appear with equal
probabilities a great example of that
would be scope resolution or pronoun
disambiguation
this one for example the trophy did not
fit in the suitcase because it was too
big
or small what does the it refer to
and was it small or big so while it
points out that the
autonyms or opposites such as small and
big
open and close occur in the same context
with equal probability so it's
impossible to statistically infer which
one is correct
but yeah i highly recommend you check
out wallet's blog he's got some
incredible stuff there
also talking about the concept of
memorizing versus understanding
and talking about how in his opinion the
tech giants are hampering progress
in cognitive computing learning from
data and observations are underrated
word embeddings the good the bad and the
ugly and there's some stuff about his
company onto logic
it's really good so make sure you check
this out so back in the days of expert
systems there was this concept of the
knowledge bottleneck
it just became incredibly onerous to
capture this knowledge because you
needed highly
specialized engineers and there was just
always more knowledge to capture
so one of the main reasons behind the
empirical data-driven revolution that
took the ai world by storm
in the early 1990s was the supposed
brittleness
of the symbolic or the logical systems
the never-ending need for more carefully
crafted rules
the paradigm changed to machine learning
in the late 1980s and the idea was that
the algorithm could
somewhat discover these rules
automatically by approximating a
probability distribution function
ironically though data scientists now
are wasting more time than ever
probably spending about 80 percent of
their time just crunching data
so did we overreact to the knowledge
bottleneck in the 1980s
tacit knowledge is normally implicit
inside the expert's head it needs to be
externalized and made
explicit so this is what led to what's
called the knowledge bottleneck
it's one of the key issues in knowledge
engineering it was said that machine
learning would help us overcome
this bottleneck but wallid said he
hasn't seen any sign of that yet
ambiguity in language is a necessary
mechanism to ensure effective
communication of thoughts
through language if things seem
ambiguous it's because they are highly
compressed
and the listener has the necessary
common knowledge to decode what's being
said
we don't transmit any redundant
information this should actually be
reassuring
perhaps this is an emergent convergent
phenomenon in humans
wallet thinks that this entails that our
common data repository can't be learned
otherwise it wouldn't be common he says
that different experiences would lead to
different knowledge
there's a lot of information we don't
convey because i assume you have it
you call it the common background
knowledge the test should be
can you uncover that information then
you're doing understanding
so if i want to follow shannon's
efficiency for communication
i leave it out because i know the
receiver has that information
the language understanding problem the
you
and that makes it different from the nlp
is finding that stuff that we take for
granted because i know you know it
but obviously we don't stop each other
on every time we're talking and say
hey wait a minute what do you mean by
that what do you mean by we don't
we understand each other very nicely we
understand each other
language is ambiguous in the sense that
we
compress things and then we try to
uncompress them
until the picture is clear but if i say
java
just told me blah blah blah blah jump as
a human
islands don't say anything wally thinks
that language
cannot be learned there's no time to
learn language it can't be learned
my god a four-year-old can barely walk
but they can speak
fluently the structure they have is much
simpler than we think
look at the word we disagree on very few
things
the way the word works physically
logically chemically
is not up to you or to me there's an
agreement otherwise you're called stupid
or doesn't know science there's very
little disagreement
in the word we live in there are facts
in this word
and these facts are undisputable that
means they're not learnable
they're not susceptible to data wallet
also believes that language
is a formal language it's not something
we figure out we have
an internal compiler it works according
to rules we just haven't
agreed on or figured out what those
rules are yet language is a formal
language
it's just that we didn't we haven't
figured out
the compiler of that damn language
right there's a compiler for natural
language
in our head that compiles natural
type checking and all it does everything
according to
rules we agreed on obviously but we
haven't figured it out
chomsky and norvik came to blows
recently and the argument was
fundamentally over
whether we should be learning from data
or whether we should seek to understand
whether it would be possible for us to
build a model of understanding
for intelligence itself norvig was one
of the ai pioneers
one of the old school he really tried to
figure this out
the old-fashioned way back in the days
of expert systems
he spent decades on it he was lavishly
funded and ultimately he failed
and now he's working for google now
he has the mindset that we should use
the petabyte storage clouds
and we should memorize and interpolate
between everything on the internet
technically theoretically deep learning
could
figure all of this out if given enough
data
learning from data has a ceiling it's
the intelligence of animals
because they do pattern recognition
actually better than the best neural
network that is out there
an eagle sees from two miles away but if
you can get to a point where you can
differentiate between a fact
between a mall and a university campus
the information you need to realize this
is not a
uh this is not a campus this is a mall
it's not in the data
i watched the presentation that wallet
did a few years ago and
he's always been quite clear with the
messaging that a lot of
ontological information is not in the
pixels it's not in the data
it's not in the text and he gave this
example in his presentation and he said
would a vision algorithm ever know that
this is a teacher and a student
and in this case would the algorithm
know that it's a mother
a daughter a family a husband a wife and
so on
so i just put it into the azure vision
api and
this doesn't look terribly good actually
it's got posing person
photo girl woman smiling young group
people man holding that's not terribly
good
to be honest so this is the the google
vision api
and here we've got person now the gender
has been removed from this
we have leisure child family pictures
family taking photos together so
semantically this seems
much richer so interestingly we can
extract that kind of semantic
information when i drag in the teacher
student one here
this is really good so learning 95
education 94
class 92 student classroom
it's done incredibly well actually it
really can tell
that this is an educational setting and
if you wrote some code here
enumerating this information you would
be able to tell that the
relationship between this woman and this
child here is that
she's a teacher rather than her mother
walled would point out though that deep
learning here has just given us basic
information
it has not given us knowledge that's not
and the data
itself if if everything is in the data
then actually we we would have
we would have a completely different
science
there are models inside there are models
like
force is mass times acceleration okay
you can try it on few
examples and you say oh it works f is
m times a on few observations but until
you figure
out that for all it's not about these
few examples that i tried
you don't have a model but the problem
with the empirical methods is
they are religious about symbols and and
admitting there are symbolic structures
let's call them whatever you want they
don't want to admit
one symbol in the system i can learn
everything
jan lacoon had a paper which i'm sure
he's ashamed of now he put on the
archive
that you can learn you can learn
language from characters
all the way up come on man come on
iman while kant was not stupid you're
not smarter than him
there's a limit to how far you can go
with your extremism
they don't want to admit one symbol
it's all neural firing they have the
inside of the brain
in their sleep like it's all firing and
wait a minute
who told if that was the case the
difference between our brain and the
chimpanzee
is what is negligible yet a chimpanzee
will take two more million years and
they will not speak
there's something else besides the
firing my friend
animal intelligence have been studied a
long time ago the best they can do
is association they cannot do the
experiment with the monkey
they put a box that if they stepped on
it they would reach the banana
but they put the box in the corner of
the room the monkey almost
went hungry they didn't do one simple
deduction
i need that much height that has that
height if then else
the difference between us and animals it
actually made my point we're almost
identical biologically
so there's something else obviously
right and if you think about it
it's language and thinking that and that
was discovered
years ago thought and language are if
and only if you can have thought
so language is not just nlp there has
been a perpetual war
about how to characterize machine
intelligence
connollyhe on last week's episode
asserted
that he thought it was an open problem
whether humans are even intelligent or
not
it has to be psychologically plausible
cognitively plausible
and computationally plausible otherwise
something is wrong right
so if you have zero knowledge
and you're trying just to look for a
needle in a haystack
you probably could find it right but
then it's the theory of computation here
uh kicks in and it's if you give me an
infinite amount of time and an
infinite amount of memory i can i can
compute anything
yes but i think what we call
intelligence is about not
needing that infinite amount of time
it's not accidental that alan turing
thought of language as the test for
intelligence
he didn't choose pattern recognition he
didn't even choose game playing i
mentioned that in my post
because games as big as they are they're
finite so if you give me enough compute
power
i'll screw it because i'll compute every
possibility and i'll have a score for
every path
you're dead 15 years ago you had to have
specialized knowledge about vision or
language processing you actually needed
to know something about the subdomain
the famous nlp researcher joe of
goldberg
he said something quite similar he
teaches a semester on nlp and he said
that it's very depressing at the moment
he doesn't know how to do it where he's
torn between two perspectives
so one teaching the interesting problems
why language is interesting and why
language is hard
how language is structured the problem
there is that he'll mostly be presenting
a set of open questions
without any good solutions to any of
them we suck at absolutely everything
he goes on to say on the other hand we
could talk about the deep learning
perspective we can teach embeddings and
bert and fine-tuning and squad these
techniques work quite well but
we don't really know why they fail a lot
and we've got no idea how to improve
the problem with this connectionist
tabarasa deep learning paradigm
is that it's so far removed from any
technical knowledge about natural
language processing
even ai pioneers like marvin minsky and
john mccarthy
were humble enough to only claim
authority on one or two subjects in
artificial intelligence
whereas now all you need to know is how
to build neural networks
you don't need to understand anything at
all
yeah but is that the good or the bad it
used to be that in data analysis we
thought that
garbage in was garbage out and all that
deep learning has changed is that
garbage in is garbage out with a high
degree of confidence it's like
getting papers out yeah it's like you
have people that
they don't know they don't know anything
and they can write a bunch of code and
there's this sort of mathematical
passport type psychology that goes
around where if it's complicated enough
and i put enough math
in there even if it's just trash when
vaswani introduced this new language
model that predicts the next word
you don't need to you don't need to know
anything about language whatsoever
you're just producing the most general
blank slate deep learning model
to predict the next word but i work in
the field i was
around ml people which now means nlp
like wait a minute nlp is not an l and
nlu is not an lp and it's not ml those
young kids who put on their linkedin
ml dash nlp dash
ai dash dl dash
internet they have no idea what language
is
for example you know what language for
them is
tokenizing stemming it's text yeah
in your article here you actually have
some technical
descriptions of concepts in language
like this one
metonymy right if you ask any
anyone who's got nlp deep learning on
their linkedin profile what that means
no no one's going to know the answer
forget it
we spend a little bit of time talking
about deep learning and wallets opinion
on deep learning
i i am not a critic of deep learning
per se not at all actually
in so many problems not only is it a
good technology it's the only technology
wallet thinks that some functions can be
solved with neural networks and those
relate to
a very small class of problems where the
solution can be approximated
by processing massive amounts of data
and finding correlations and
memorization
especially when there are a finite
number of solutions like
go or chess for example now you really
have people that believe
a 10 line algorithm back propagation
and the gradient descent method explains
the mind
that has to be on its own before i dig
into
the details on its own that's got to be
ridiculous
we do all kinds of reasoning statistical
reasoning is one of them
we do default reasoning we do analogical
reasoning we do
our mind cannot be explained by base
theorem and back propagation
things i can teach in half an hour
please and all those philosophers and
all those
brilliant logicians that work for
centuries on this problem
cannot be idiots
you mr young guy who just took two
courses and you know tensorflow and
pytorch
they're not idiots baby you are i have a
friend of mine his son
is i'm that old his son wants to do grad
studies
and ai and he said he couldn't find an
advisor that would take him because he
doesn't want to do deep learning
he loves deep learning actually he toys
with it but he wants to do ai
with a different paradigm and he can
because all the funding all the
conferences
they're all google they're all facebook
if you don't do deep learning screw you
and now even in government funding if
your research
doesn't have deep learning every other
word no money so
that's not good we speak about the
potentially flawed ways in which we
evaluate
natural language processing models it's
never in a novel it's like and frank
entered the door and then mary said to
frank
what did the in the last sentence of
this very novel referred to
that never happened so so so if
i enter the corner table wants a beer
and then i ask it to continue the text
and the next sentence is
all right let's get the guy one or all
right let's get the couple another
set of glasses then to me that means the
neural network
understands that there is a person
whether or not in internally does this
whole logic reasoning is a different
question
you have an innate ontological structure
the entire
ontology is like 2 000 types
something you can code in one day the
nearest term to an ontological concept
is what logicians
and mathematicians have for centuries
called natural kinds
these are concepts which just exist
humans didn't make them
these concepts are not defined of
conditions or criteria
they just are we actually do type
checking
and when the types have a mismatch we do
type unification
and that's how we discover the missing
text there is a way to uncover what you
didn't say
there like the corner table wants
another beer
want and wants a beer expects a human
you found a table so you do unification
and you figure out
what is the salient relationship between
person and table
and you discover what is meant is the
person sitting at the table wanted
so there are types that are in your type
checking
basically you're type checking in
language
it's like a formal language to me
is about saying let me make sense out of
what was said
and after you tried to make sense out of
what was said you discover the stuff
that wasn't said
that's what goes into the mind and the
mind applies now the innate knowledge
that ontological structure that
information cannot all be numeric
this comes to the intentionality we can
do with intentions obviously we pass
richer structures than that now if you
combine that with the learnability
the power of the neural net is the
learnability
if you combine learnability with richer
structures
man you're on to something but you want
to fix it on vectors and numbers
i don't believe that information is in
the data itself
there's another structure that powers
and constrains
these degrees of freedom that are all
over the place
there's a constraining system inside
kids show us this so jane was wearing a
beautiful red dress and no one would
ever say a red beautiful dress
so there's a lot of evidence that tells
us there's something that can strain all
these possibilities
wallet believes that knowledge graphs
don't actually contain knowledge
they contain structured information
usually in triples so
entity relation entity so looking at
wallets
information hierarchy going from data
through information and knowledge
walid asserts that we start from signals
so being able to make very basic type
judgments
and data is just uninterpreted signals
and strings and literals
and then we move to the next level of
the hierarchy which is information
so information is a meaningful
organization of data
we can say things about all instances of
a type using these typed functions
so humans articulate humans make
artifacts
an event is imminent the most enriched
level of information or data is
knowledge
knowledge is when we can create
functional and typed constraints
over data there's so much ambiguity in
information
and what we need is a very rich ontology
or a kind of type
system so that we can constrain all of
the possibilities
so there's a great example here that
olga is an agent
and she's attractive a knowledge base is
basically just data it's just structured
data so here we have
some personnel information and whether
or not they have children so for example
elvis presley
has a child lisa marie presley
so far this is just a structured
database but what we can do is we can
add
structured knowledge so we can say what
does it mean to be a daughter
between two entities if the entity y is
a child of entity x
and if the gender of x is a female then
we know that means
it's a daughter of x and we can do the
same thing with sun
so now if we ask the question does elvis
have any suns
we can enumerate the children of elvis
and we can check that the gender
is male so we can go to google we can
say how many children did elvis have and
it says
one children lisa marie presley so then
i say how many
sons did elvis have it says one but
that information is incorrect and if we
could have this rich conception of
knowledge
that we've just shown here we would be
able to infer
that elvis did not have any sons many
people said
to understand human communication we
have to reverse engineer language itself
the final representation has to be
language agnostic otherwise you're doing
something wrong
technically wallet is not a symbolic
person either
you have to reduce it all to internal
stuff
that we all have otherwise you're doing
symbolic stuff so that's why
the symbolic camp also doesn't like what
i'm doing so
i'm stuck in between now we had some
great comments on the last video that we
did with conor leahy
and one particularly good comment was
from v-drak
and v-drak wanted to hit in on our claim
that
these statistical language models are
just memorizing everything on the
internet
so on the annex original video on gbt3
he basically said that
it's very clever interpolation it's
memorizing things to some extent
vidrak pointed out that there are
several places in the video where he
said something along the lines of
i would be impressed if it could do this
where actually it turned out to do
exactly that so if we come down into the
examples that vidrak
gives later on here so gwen is a very
interesting character i've been
following him on and off for about 15
years i think and he references this
database prompt which was an experiment
by
matt brockman let's read this now the
database begins knowing nothing the
database knows everything that's added
to it the database does not know
anything else
when asked a question if the answer has
been added to the database the database
says the answer
when asked a question if the answer has
not been added the database says it does
not know
so this is insane we've just described a
computer program using natural language
question does the database know what is
two plus two
answer the database does not know
question does the database know what is
the capital of france
the database does not know tom is 20
years old is added to the database
question does the database know where
tom lives answer
the database does not know question how
does the database respond to tom's age
the database says tom is 20 years old
question how does the database respond
when asked what is my age the database
says
you are not in the database this is
absolutely fascinating it's almost as if
we've constructed a computer program
using natural language and gpt3 seems to
be performing some kind of reasoning
beyond which you would expect from
interpolation
it clearly opens up a new paradigm of
application development
and also it makes us redefine our
conception of intelligence
so vdrack also cites this online fitness
ai knowledge beta now this is actually
hooked up to gbt3 so you can query gbt3
if you formulate your question to look
like a fitness question
so here we can paste in vdrak's example
which is
written in python code so there's an
array here fitness health and heart
in b there's another array which is
lifting curls and squats
and c is running and jogging and then
the prompt is
so what is b dot append push up so it's
asking a python
program in question in natural language
so we go ahead and we run this
and it gives the answer it says the
answer of b dot append push-ups is
lifting curls squats and push-ups so
it's
understood what is b and
what would happen if we appended
push-ups to b
and it's given us the answer invalid
python code this is just
unreal the other thing v-drag points out
is in the original gpt3 paper
they said that it doesn't really do
addition when there are many digits
but this might be explained by the pair
encoding problem
for efficiency and to reduce the number
of tokens going into gbt3
it does by pair encoding and what that
means is that
if tokens appear frequently together
they get
atomized into one token so you can see
here that
this person is going through all the
different three-digit numbers and
showing you whether they are one token
or whether they are two tokens
and there's a fairly strong possibility
that this is the reason why
gpt3 couldn't do addition to many digits
it had nothing to do with it memorizing
particular combinations on the internet
and everything to do with this coding
so if you put commas in so you
circumvent the byte encoding
then gpt3 can do addition up to about
nine or ten digits
reasonably reliably and that does seem
to imply that
it is actually doing a level of
generalization beyond which we thought
before
v drag also points out this interesting
example here which is
the letters in jogging are j o g g ing
now notice that spaces between the
letters there are to avoid the byte
pairing coding problem
and scrambled they are g o j g
n i g what are the letters squatting and
what are they scrambled and then the
answer is note the letters in squatting
are squatting and scrambled they are t
i n g s q u a now that's actually
missing one of the letters but this is
incredible
what we've done is we've described an
algorithm in natural language
and we've just one-shotted it and gpt-3
knows what we want to do
this is absolutely mind-blowing to me so
i have to update my position a little
bit here
before i thought that gpt3 was just
memorizing and interpolating between
examples on the internet
what we're seeing here is an example of
one-shotting or few shotting and being
able to perform fairly sophisticated
tasks
it may not be reasoning maybe it's still
just looking at some kind of statistical
patterns in the data that would be
impossible for us to understand
but it's now learned this representation
that is so sophisticated
that it can do things which appear like
intelligence to us
it does make us redefine our conception
of intelligence
another thing that happened recently is
yan lacoon has come out there and
criticized gbt3 he says that some people
have completely unrealistic expectations
about what large-scale language models
like like gpt3 can do
so he says that gbt3 is a language model
which means that
when you feed it text and ask it to
predict the continuation of the text one
word at a time
gpt3 doesn't have any knowledge of how
the world actually works
it only appears to have some level of
background knowledge to the extent that
this knowledge is present in the
statistics of text
but this knowledge is very shallow and
disconnected from the underlying reality
yan lacoon is basically agreeing with
walid sabha
saying here today that we do have a rich
common ontological knowledge store in
our minds
and this tells us about how the world
works
and we need to have this common
knowledge store in order to unpack the
information that we receive
via language so this article also blew
up on hacker news
some of the comments here are talking
about the philosophical question of
whether knowledge
and language are the same thing or
whether knowledge is separate clearly
wallid sabha believes that knowledge is
separate that we have an innate
hierarchy of types or natural kinds in
our minds
that are baked into us or bootstrapped
pretty much soon after we
we are born and this allows us to decode
or unpack the information transmitted in
language
language is very ambiguous and without
this
unpacking or knowledge representation
that we have in our minds we wouldn't be
able to make sense of anything
so lefty ted said i think this is a
philosophical question there is a view
that basically there's no such thing as
knowledge
just language or at least there is no
distinction between knowledge and
language
in this view all there really is is
language which is mostly composed of
metaphors
and ultimately metaphors only refer to
other metaphors
languages circular in this view not only
is the ultimate physical concrete world
beyond us
but we also can't even talk about it
from this perspective gbg3 is not
substantially different from what our
minds are doing
the same person also made a comment
later on invoking george lakov now and
walid saba in
invoked george lacov towards the end of
our presentation today
we in english use war metaphors to talk
about arguments
of arguments and of wars you can say
things like he's marshalling his forces
they're ceding their territory or she's
girding her defenses
in fact almost anything you can say
about a war
you can also say about an argument in
american politics with regard to
partisan squabbling and filibuster
we talk about the nuclear option the
fact that these metaphors make sense to
us
indicates a judgment something like
arguments are like wars
that judgment shows up in billions of
lines of english scraped from the
internet and can be fed into a model
allowing gpt3 to make that connection
via purely statistical methods
yes this is a bit like asking what a
library believes but a lot of these
metaphors shows up in our language
and by the way they express judgments
which is something akin to a belief
does that mean a library has beliefs is
this all knowledge is
i wouldn't go that far but the argument
is an interesting one and worth raising
very interesting so there was a paper
just released in minds and machines
called
gpt3 its nature scope limits
and consequences by luciano floridi
he says in the abstract that this is a
reminder that gpt3 does not do
what it is not supposed to do and that
any interpretation of gpt3
as the beginning of the emergence of a
general form of artificial intelligence
is merely uninformed science fiction so
luciano talks about this concept of
irreversibility
which is very similar to walid's concept
of the missing text
also the ambiguity and language who
mowed the lawn ambrogio
who is a robotic lawnmower or alice
we know that the two are different in
everything bodily cognitively
in terms of their information and
processing qualities
and behaviorally in terms of their
external actions yet it is impossible
to infer with full certainty from the
mode lawn
to who mowed it so irreversibility and
reversibility are not a new idea
in our brains we know that people mow
lawns
we also know ontologically that robotic
lawn mowers
mow lawns so it's impossible for us to
infer
in this situation which entity mowed the
lawn it's completely ambiguous
but this concept of reversibility is
really interesting so one of the
experiments that luciano did here
was asking gpt-3 tell me how many feet
fit in a shoe
gpt3 gives a nonsensical answer i don't
know said the boy how many just load a
nonsense
walid sabo would argue that gpg3 doesn't
understand because it doesn't have the
rich ontological structure
in our mind that can allow us to fill in
the missing gaps in that information
anyway i hope you enjoyed the episode
today remember to like
comment and subscribe we love reading
your comments next week we have an
incredibly exciting guest
frankly i don't know how the hell we
managed to pull this off
but it's actually happening so tune in
next week for a surprise guest
cheers i i think we're in three time
zones
so we've got new york yeah you're in
california right
and then i'm in london and the annex in
switzerland
so it's four yeah so welcome back
to the machine learning street talk
youtube channel with me
tim scarf my two compadres yannick
lightspeed culture
keith bayesian mit phd duggar
and uh today we have a very special
guest walid saber
now wallid is an expert in natural
language understanding
ontology knowledge engineering
conversational ai
and personalized recommendations he's
quite prolific on linkedin actually
i discovered him on linkedin he's got a
huge loyal following and he makes some
really insightful
posts and lots of entertaining
commentary so that was how i discovered
wallet he's also got a blog on medium
where he talks about his views on
natural language understanding
and to summarize his views a little bit
he thinks that it's time that we put an
end to bertology bertology is the name
that walid
uses to describe the current kind of
deep learning or statistical approaches
to natural language processing
he thinks that natural language
understanding is not the same thing as
natural language processing he cites the
missing text phenomenon
so many of our utterances in our
language are compressed
we leave out crucial information that
there's an example that he cites
the corner table wants a beer well
actually we're referring to the person
at the corner table wants a beer
and these words are never spoken so
statistical models would never find out
that we're talking about a person
and he says that this is the same across
all languages not just a thing in
english
so he says that there are many instances
in language where statistics will not
allow us to resolve the meaning
he also talks about this really
interesting concept from the logic world
which is intention
versus extension which means that
language actually has
almost no degrees of freedom and i'm
sure we'll get into that shortly
he also thinks that word embeddings and
of course we all know about word
embeddings he thinks that they're just
not
fit for purpose for describing language
because they only have a
very one-dimensional relation to each
other he's advocating that we should
have a rich
typing system capturing the ontological
structure
in language anyway a bit about wallid's
career
he's the co-founder and principal
scientist at ontologic which is a
company that
has been around for about a year or so
he was a principal ai scientist at
astound for three years
he was the co-founder and cto at clangu
for six and a half years
and he's also held many other impressive
positions in companies
he's got a very long illustrious career
but he was also the associate professor
at the american university of technology
at the american university of beirut he
was an assistant professor at the
university of windsor so that was a
period spanning about seven years or so
and he's got a phd in computer science
from carleton university
and also a bachelor's and a masters in
computer science from the university of
windsor
walid it's an absolute honour to have
you on the show thank you so much for
joining us
oh my god it's my privilege my uh honor
i thank you for actually inviting me
and i hope i will have something useful
to say
as you can tell i am very passionate
about
ai for me ai is my kids
all my life i've thought about my kids
and ai sometimes
one more than the other i'm not going to
say which so i've lived with ai for 30
years before it was a cool subject
and i lived through the ai winter
believe it or not where i took
everything called ai from my cv and i
sold myself as a software engineer after
all i'm a computer scientist
and i live the the transition
from the gophi the good
old-fashioned ai into empirical ai
let's call it empirical as opposed to
birthology for now
where things started to go statistical
nlp
you mentioned word embeddings there was
gary salton who was a pioneer
in in the text retrieval information
retrieval award it was a big thing back
then document retrieval
where he came up with the vector model
for
representing documents with vectors and
then do the cosine similarity and that
was the
that was the measure of similarity we're
talking in the 60s right so the idea is
not
entirely new it's like deep learning is
not entirely new
they are more powerful neural networks
we have
a lot more computing power but same
paradigm
back propagation and you optimize
through stochastic
gradient descent the model is
essentially the same
and the idea of representing content
with vectors
believe me before the end of the 60s
that's how old it is so
there's nothing new under the sun really
if you think about it
okay i'm probably exaggerating a bit but
not much believe me
so i've lived in this world for many
years on an interdisciplinary
sort of guy i go to neuroscience
psychology linguistics philosophy
statistics logic so
i don't like it when i see extremism now
you really have people that believe a 10
line algorithm back propagation
and the gradient descent method explains
the mind
that has to be on its own before i dig
into
the details on its own that's gotta be
ridiculous
the problem is the runaway train is
going so
wild that nobody would listen i have
colleagues of mine very respectable
people that i met at bell labs or
ibm watson in my other life
and i chat with them and i say hey
vlodec what the hell's going on man
what happened to ai he said don't talk
to me
i don't want to i don't want to mention
the subject i talk to people
and after two minutes i say okay end of
discussion you're right
so i hope i give a good background where
i'm coming from
i'm very passionate about this so all
i'm trying on my blog
is to hopefully bring some sanity into
the discussion like
guys take it easy we do all kinds of
reasoning statistical reasoning is one
of them
we do default reasoning we do we do
analogical reasoning we do
our mind cannot be explained by base
theorem and back propagation
things i can teach in half an hour
please and all those philosophers and
all those
brilliant logicians that worked for
centuries on this problem
cannot be idiots
you mister young guy who just took two
courses and you know tensorflow and by
torch
they're not idiots maybe you are so
that's it
yeah there's i have a lot of sympathy
just uh fy for those views i think this
is what
plonk max blanc got to with his kind of
statement that's often paraphrased as
science advances one funeral at a time
there are these very
real human sociological and
psychological
kind of issues that just flat out get in
the way
of scientific progress because people
start to associate
their personal identity with whatever
they're working on
and then it becomes essentially a
religion almost a process of faith
if you will actually he was quoted by
jeff hinton and i think
in triple ai 18 or something
and and i give credit to hinton he said
the next thing that's going to be cool
is someone who's going to tell me
everything you did is rubbish
come on guys take it easy and he coded
max blank yeah
and thomas kuhn quoted him as well in
his book i think it's the structure of
scientific revolutions that kind of
really lays out this phenomenon that we
see repeated time and time again
yeah it's it's just that the this time
around i've never seen it like this
those psychological and social and
personal issues
have always been they've always been
part of science
russell and freyja used to criticize
each other in the press it was always i
know the truth
and so we always had that but not to the
extent where
i think what happened now is
big tech took over and
and took over in an unhealthy way i have
an article about that
because apparently the paradigm suits
the big data guess who has big data
who has big compute the cloud guess who
owns it so
it was a beautiful paradigm now nvidia
is talking about ai
right so many things happened
but it's really unhealthy i have a
friend of mine his son
is i'm that old his son wants to do grad
studies
in ai and he said he couldn't find an
advisor that would take him
because he doesn't want to do deep
learning he loves deep learning actually
he toys with it
but he wants to do ai with a different
paradigm and he can
because all the funding all the
conferences they're all google they're
all facebook if you don't do deep
learning screw you
and now even in government funding if
your research
doesn't have deep learning every other
word no money so
that's not good that's not good so i'm
curious yet are you running because
you're
in the you know phd student world today
right what are you running into
i was the first one here to do deep
learning and then you spoke to other
phds and he's like oh what do you do
like yeah i'm trying
to get into deep learning oh my
professor doesn't allow that
they would be like you'd he you'd have
this feeling this distributed feeling
that it was coming
it's coming like we see it in other
places and so on but
most of the professors were actually
like nah that's rubbish i can't prove
anything
about it and so on and now as you say
it's almost the opposite you say i want
to do something else and
it's weight you so what neural network
do you solve the problem with
that's almost so i had a question
with respect to birthology and and your
criticisms of all of this
and just to clarify i'm i
understood that by birthology you don't
only mean
like the latest iteration of statistical
nlp i guess you would say the same thing
about lstms before that
and so on the approach of statistical
processing do you think it's getting
worse in kind of a continuous manner or
is it really like we do this or we do
the other
what's here yes that's a good point
actually i start my article saying
data driven statistical so i i love all
of those together basically
probably the best word for that is
empirical methods right
the methods where you're trying to or
you're trying to figure out language
by processing the data essentially
trying to figure out how long
a language works by looking at the
observation which is text right so all
of these approaches yeah they
include statistical nlp they include
so but because it's
i i actually vertology is not mine i
found it in a paper and
i just loved i loved it because you have
birth and you have berta and you have
alberta and you have so basically you
have virtology and
the gp21 gp22 gpd3 and i expect gp220
20 years from now it will understand a
little bit more than my
uh three-year-old but hey it will go on
but so all of that for me is parthology
right it's empirical methods
and my problem is i i have to actually
mention this
i i am not a critic of deep learning
per se not at all actually
in so many problems not only is it a
good technology
it's the only technology so let me
qualify what i'm saying
deep learning and similar approaches are
really pattern recognition technologies
right and pattern recognition actually
i'm working on an engine nlu engine at
the bottom
it's vectors it's vectors
because you need to ground your
your semantics in something unlike
i i have a problem with both camps these
years unlike symbolic approaches where a
word is defined by words like
okay there's the grounding problem like
where does this get its meaning from
this is where word embeddings were
brilliant it gets its meaning guess from
where
from how we use it wow that was
huge my problem is
at the highest level you do all kinds of
reasoning man
just to resolve references just to
resolve quantifiers code
so monkeys do pattern recognition but
they can't do quantifier scope
resolution
so we're not as intelligent as just
elephants
the the ceiling of our technology is
pattern recognition
but are we aiming to create an ai as
smart as
a rat they do amazing pattern
recognition
and that's the ceiling of deep learning
i can sign in
any color ink you want on that
the ceiling of deep learning whatever
you want to call it
and it's deep or shallow or wide or
whatever
learning from data has a ceiling it's
the intelligence of animals
because they do pattern recognition
actually better than the best neural
network that is out there
an eagle sees from two miles away so my
problem is
applying it to language so vision for
example
is all pattern recognition god that's
what it is
speech anything that has to do with
finding patterns in data
beautiful but that was one thing i
wanted to ask you about because you've
asserted in several of your talks that
you think that vision
is pattern recognition but language
isn't and i would dispute that because i
think that
there is a rich ontological structure if
you like
in the vision world as well and you have
to do spatial reasoning just as you
might
with language right just just before we
get to that right
no but if you may if you make okay
vision is not image and scene analysis
or scene understanding
in that domain if you want to go that
far
you're going to go beyond deep learning
and do reasoning
just to be i'm saying image recognition
in other words
recognizing that this is not a cat this
is a horse
i haven't done i haven't done any
interpretation of the image
once you get there deep learning of
course it's not enough
i think some deep learning practitioners
would disagree with you
and think that we could have um
sophisticated inductive priors or
we actually yeah actually i have a
challenge also in one of my posts
no one has met it yet to the deep
learning community
i say let's do a sample data sample
of images that i would like you to
differentiate between
for example if you can get to a point
where you can differentiate between a
fact
between a mall and a university campus
both have the same both have the same
ontological concepts
people trees buildings blah blah blah
the information you need to realize this
is not a
this is not a campus this is a mall it's
not in the data
that's you're touching all the points
that i want to get to this is super
interesting
so just before we get there one step
back i think it
a good way of framing your belief is
that you think
natural language is a formal language
and what that means is that it can be
systematically explained
and it's not ambiguous in any way and
that's very much the chomsky
school of thought as well i'm always
lumped with trump i don't know why
chomsky represented everybody else
he became the compliment of me so if
it's not then
then then it's chomsky the compliment
everything else
no chomsky belongs to a school at a high
level yes we are in the same
paradigm but if you go down if you go
down the anthology i'm not a chomskin at
all actually i
i come from the freyja russell fred
summers the metaphysical
the the innate that we have an innate
ontological structure
that we don't there's no time to learn
language it can't be learned there's no
way
look at kids how they speak so i come
from that school
i share with chomsky few things yes that
language is an innate module
there's no way we learn it there's a lot
of proof but we never told our kids if
you have beautiful and read in the
sentence you put beautiful before right
although we said although okay but i'm
not trump's game but i got your point
so the reason chomsky assimilated
everyone else is because he stepped into
the
conspiracy theory world order political
kind of uh spectrum and and then
therefore if you're not if you're not a
chomsky is
it's because you're trying to hide the
fact that you're part of you know some
conspiracy so
actually ironically enough ironically
enough on that part i'm with him
anyway the thing is you said something
really interesting because you gave the
example
of the mall and in a minute i'm going to
get you to explain
the difference between logical and
ontological concepts but you said
something very instructive
which is that the information about them
all is not in the pixels and this
actually generalizes to your argument
about language because you think the
same thing
but right now in one of your youtube
presentations you gave an example
about three years ago of a picture of a
woman it was a family it was a mother
and there was also a picture of a
student and and a female
teacher and you you said that it it's
reasonably straightforward to figure out
that there's a woman in the image but
the what you call the logical concepts
like the fact that she's a mother
and it's a student you said that's
beyond the realms of
deep learning but i put the same image
into the google vision classifier
and it said that it was a mother in the
student and teacher example as well it
said that it was a student and teacher
it's a similar concept with intelligence
that every time we increase on our
benchmarks and we do something that we
couldn't do last week
there's always a chorus of people that
say oh that's not really intelligence
the goal the goal posts keep moving all
the time and you said yourself because
you cited an example that you think
intelligence is not about needing
millions of examples
francois chile says the same we need to
be more efficient
right that's a good point actually you
make a good point
but i'm not one of those naysayers every
time i no no i'm a true believer in
science and i'm true believer of
things can progress and you you still
probably
i don't know enough about deep learning
i still say that up to now
but so i'm not one of those uh no that's
not no
intelligence happens one battle at a
time because that's how we're
intelligent
i'm a materialist scientist we have
atoms in the end
and they create somehow intelligence if
it did happen
i don't know how many you tried but i
can give you a setting
where no image recognition will get it
not because i tried it and
and it failed or i tried it and it
worked no
theoretically theoretically there's
information that's not and the data
itself if if everything is in the data
then actually we we would have
we would have a completely different
science there
there are models inside there are models
like
force is mass times acceleration okay
you can try it on few
examples and you say oh it works f is
m times a on few observations but until
you figure out
that for all it's not about these few
examples that i tried
you don't have a model can i make this a
bit more symbolic just for the moment
because i just want to set up a context
for the rest of the conversation
otherwise i'm going to be personally
confused you made an argument i think it
was a proof number one
which kind of said it was this argument
about learning is compression
um and therefore since natural language
understanding is about
decoding and not compression it's it's
not learnable
i think we can define natural under
natural language understanding
as a relation that has three parts of
the the ordered
set which is the utterances
and semantic structures that are
associated with that utterance
and this is the data that you're saying
we essentially don't have which is the
kind of semantic structure that we build
from the utterance and then a
probability associated with that
with that that no we do send a lot of
information
if we don't send anything then i'm going
to say speak up
what do you want to tell me no we do
send quite a bit
but amazingly through a couple of
hundred thousand years of
evolution we found out the optimal
amount of information i need to send
and we kept out things that i don't need
to send because i know
i understood that so i'm asking is this
a fair is this a fair
structuring mathematically of what
natural language
understanding is a relation between
utterances
semantic structures and a probability
it's missing one thing
k or call it bk
the background knowledge that type of
prior knowledge
that i call it prior knowledge and it's
the knowledge i have
and i am certain that you have common
knowledge
we call it common for a good reason
because it is common i so
that's yeah but it's this part is
essential because
you can study how big is that part
compared to the others
so in other words how much is innate how
much
do i know you know about the physical
world that if you
you never taught a kid that if you let
go of the mug it's going to fall down
we come with a lot of common terms not
not just in language
but actually no i agree with you it's
even things that are encoded you know
genetically
right that's been there from evolution
but just for the sake of argument i'm
just saying suppose that we could
codify all that in some language
whatever it is the utterances are in
english
s is in semantic graphs k is in symbolic
logic of some kind second order logic
whatever
that corpus of knowledge i would argue
is compressible
and then therefore learnable where am i
going wrong
you're going around a few places let me
in one place the word compressible when
the amount of information
we need let me give you just a simple
example
i i i think if it is compressible
then the background knowledge we have
has redundancies and it does
let me give you an example the adjective
ordering restriction
it's natural for us to say i bought a
beautiful red car
we don't say and this is in all
languages
we don't say i bought a red beautiful
car
even kids they don't know why it just
comes out this way
yeah and this is you arguing that we
have an innate ontological structure
we have an innate ontological structure
how type checking happens in type
programming languages
we actually do type checking and when
the types have a mismatch
we do type unification and that's how we
discover the missing text
i don't want to go into my engine now
but there is a way to uncover what you
didn't
say there like the corner table wants
another beer
want and wants a beer expects a human
you found a table so you do unification
and you figure out
what is the salient relationship between
person and table
and you discover what is meant is the
person sitting at the table wanted
so there are types that are in your type
checking
basically you're type checking in
language
it's like a formal language to me
is about saying let me make sense out of
what was said
and after you tried to make sense out of
what was said you discover the stuff
that wasn't said
so that to make it make sense okay
my point here is decay is not
compressible at all
we don't have redundancies in our
ontological system
so you would take issue with step number
two right that nlu is not
compressible i'm agnostic on that point
because since we don't actually have
this
nobody has sat down and codified human
knowledge and the semantic structures
and utterances i don't know
maybe it's compressible maybe it's not
just for the sake of argument
let's suppose that it was compressible
and we did have this giant corpus
and we could learn it with a neural
network that's all possible but i think
the stronger argument that you make is
actually argument three
in the paper which is even if we could
do that it would be a
atrociously inefficient way of learning
it that a neural network
that would need to capture all the k if
you will
by inferring some function some relation
here
i think is just not the right
mathematical structure to do that in
that they're it's probably a combination
of
neural networks plus expert systems plus
some other stuff that we haven't thought
of yet
actually that brings up a great point i
have a friend of mine who
worked with judea pearl who doesn't need
introduction
and he worked on belief networks and
bayesian networks
and he's now a professor at ucla but
and so he comes from somewhere in the
middle if you want
and he was talking exactly about the
computational plausibility of
a paradigm doesn't have to be only
it has to be psychologically plausible
cognitively plausible
and computationally plausible otherwise
something is wrong right that should be
part
of your judging something so
if you have zero knowledge and you're
trying just to
look for a needle in a haystack
you probably could find it right but
then it's the theory of computation here
kicks in and it's if you give me an
infinite amount of time and an
infinite amount of memory i can i can
compute anything
yes but i think what we call
intelligence is about not needing that
infinite amount of time
it's finding it is finding it in a
microsecond
somehow if you look at the mechanics of
reference resolution
my god four year olds i i was working on
this algorithm 20 years ago and i said
holy crap a kid goes through all of that
to resolve
he and they have the answer before you
it's in like almost zero time it's so
intelligence is not about
give me everything and don't worry one
day
yeah if i memorize everything then i
have the answer for everything
but and it's a hash table where i have
this
pattern and i have the answer for it but
is that intelligence
i doubt it look at kids look at how we
do things so
he was working on models where he showed
if you want to do some induction
without any prior knowledge the
computational complexity and he was
looking at simple problems
where beyond even the hardware we have
now
if you feed it a couple of rules a
couple of don't do this
and couple of restrictions this is like
optimization of some constraints
give a couple of constraints and all of
a sudden it goes to linear and even log
but just quickly on on that though
charlay said that
i don't know if you read his measure of
intelligence paper but he thinks that
intelligence is normalized by
priors and experience so to a certain
extent he would argue that if you
already encode all the knowledge into a
system then it's not
intelligent anymore it's actually the
information conversion
yeah i probably also disagree a bit
because it then it depends what you call
intelligence right if you
he's just defining learning at that
point like intelligent learning not
really
well and it's just being intelligent
right may i
shortly summarize a bit what i
understand from this
it's that your argument is that when we
transmit information with language what
we do
is we take the utterance that comes in
and we apply a set of rules
like a grammar a formal language we
deconstruct it into
its meaning let's say and technically
theoretically
deep learning could figure all of this
out if given enough data
but it's so computationally heavy
it makes no sense to do that and it's
not possible so
there must be these kind of rules in the
background
and since no one ever tells a kid these
rules
the argument is that they come pre-built
in
to you yes except the stuff that we do
is as minimal even if i figure and this
is where the rule-based traditional
logic symbolic went wrong by the way
they had complicated systems and
complicated rules and they tried to
model
intention by modalities and possible
words semantics and blah blah blah
and it was all greek for nothing because
what's missing
ironically enough not the rules inside
but the data
[Music]
look there's data that we process and
the utterance is data
but there's data that's missing okay i
call it information it's data
it's that ontological structure which is
data not
rules it's actually passive information
it's not
functions it's not rules it's not
procedures
it's data that constrain the word in
such ways
that it will tell me this utterance
could mean
two million things but because of your
type constraints inside that's what it
means man that's it
so what's missing is not rules actually
we apply now rules and we do parsing we
do semantic analysis blah blah blah
even if you figured 100 percent
accurately the semantic structure of or
said
it's not enough that's what goes into
the mind and the mind applies now the
innate knowledge
that ontological structure tim if you
want to discuss the difference between
logical and anthropological concepts
it will make it probably clear where i'm
coming from i think
you said the nearest terms to an
ontological concept
is what logicians and mathematicians
have called natural kinds so they're
concepts that exist
and concepts that um humans have made or
come up with whereas
exactly yeah and and i think that term
came
first from quan wine was the first to
use the word natural kind
in other words there are trees we did
not make the concept tree
we did not make the concept mountain we
saw a mountain and we gave it a label
essentially yeah we said
let's call it a mountain in english but
there are concepts we made up
there is no leader in the world we made
a concept called leader
and so it's a logical concept because it
satisfies certain conditions and
yeah but how do you differentiate the
two it seems it's an arbitrary
differentiation
whereas i i would argue
all of these concepts are just defined
in terms of usefulness
to human existence a mountain is a
mountain because
it's in the way and a leader is a leader
because
my society organizes itself yeah yeah i
i'm not putting an interpretation on
different concepts
i'm being more formalist than that let
me and it's not ad hoc at all
maybe we should privately discuss the
system i'm working on
here's it's not ad hoc at all just on
this point
a leader if it can be reduced further
to ontological concepts things
in the world then it's still a logical
concept it's decomposable a tree is a
tree and if i chop it in half
it's not a tree anymore it's a tree uh
okay let me put this if i chop the
leader in half it's not a leader anymore
and that doesn't apply to a leader
because a leader is not an ontological
okay here's the thing a leader is
someone
that does something so i said
in my post about vision and you can't go
beyond
you need to go beyond the data a teacher
for example
teacher did not there was no teacher if
there was no teaching
exists and teaching is an is an
ontological concept
like a tree that i can observe so we
call that thing that's happening
teaching
and then we call the agent of that
activity a teacher
otherwise there is no teacher so look
the
the so a teacher is in language is
common noun
like apple right both common nouns but
ontologically they're completely
different
and this is where logic screwed up in
logic both of them are predicates so you
have a predicate called
three x it's true if x is a three and
you have a predicate called
leader x and it's true if no they
screwed up
predicates are not types you need to
test if someone is a leader
you don't need a test you just have to
look to know if something is a tree the
difference is
huge so could i make the assertion then
that you're strongly advocating for the
need for some kind of a type hierarchy
and this is one of the things that you
say with word embeddings for example you
use the word analogies and
you say if only we knew that suitcases
and bags were the same type
but in the 1980s people advocated for
this they said if only we had bigger
knowledge graphs then eventually we
would have artificial general
intelligence but
what i love about word embeddings is
that they have this um
they have this kind of um continuous
geometric notion so rather than being
atomic
you could actually interpolate between a
mountain and a tree
and i think there's something magic
about that look word embeddings as i
already said
are a genius invention if for nothing
they converted words into things i can
compute
with that alone is a huge scientific
advance i can now compute with words
that so you don't have to sell me on the
brilliance of word embeddings right
because no because people appreciate
different things than i do
i appreciate the fact that i converted
words
into things i can add and subtract wow
that's huge man that's so it's a huge
advance
but in word embeddings i also have a
post about that you can
the only thing you can hope for at the
end is similarity
one relation is that strictly true
though because these
word embeddings typically have 300
dimensions if you use the pre-trained
ones
those dimensions could correspond and i
use them but
in the end the only output
out of two embeddings is a similarity
or equality because equality is a
similarity with degree one
now you cannot even do sub
you cannot determine i tried i used the
glove 300 dimension i tried to come up
with
some algorithms that i can predict type
hierarchy
so for example here's the thing you
cannot even do
subtyping in in with word embedded you
cannot figure out
that a bag and a suitcase are both a
container
i tried my best believe me i was hoping
for uh
are they not clustered together i don't
know whether this is the same thing but
you talked about intention and extension
right and right surely by only um taking
the scalar product or the cosine between
two vectors you're doing what you say
other people do which is only looking at
the value and the extension
if i can respond here though tim the
point is sure they'll cluster but they
can only cluster around
one point in that right in that
hyper-dimensional space
and therefore they can't cluster around
more than one type what's missing
structure there's power in structure
this was a heading i read
when i was 18. there's power and
structure once you impose a structure
the power you get the extra knowledge
you get so for example
by by by knowing that bags and suitcases
and briefcases blah blah blah are all
containers of some sort a lot by one
link
there was a classic paper for woods he
said what's in a link
there's a lot in the link the problem
with neural nets there's no structure
actually that brings me up to another
point when you compose these tensors
in one layer into the next you lost the
structure
because the resulting tensor cannot be
decomposed now in a decidable way
its decomposition is infinite could i
just um challenge that a tiny bit i know
what you're saying there's not a
structure in the sense that these are
distributed representations but
actually there are rich manifolds and
topologies here so for example
you use the corner table as a person who
wants a beer
well using some topological reasoning
you could actually quite easily find
that there's a person involved surely
but why not something else people
frequent bars
could you not uh find that out do you
mean
because there are other objects in the
room than the table
there are yeah there are yeah i suppose
i'm saying that if you have
enough examples of bars you would be
able to
walk some kind of graph to infer
essentially that these type of entities
exist in bars
but then why is it a person there are
many other entities in the bar
there are codes there are chairs there
what i'm trying to say right right
what i'm saying is the knowledge is
simple
want expects a person and a
three-year-old knows that
end of story otherwise look we go back
to yeah if i see all different
combinations
forever yeah maybe i can come up with
this but i don't think that's
what we do ironically enough the deep
learning people come
from biological plausibility inspired by
the brain although that's not how the
neural network
but then they forget every other
possibility like why are you
i mean it's not even biologically
plausible or cognitively plausible
if we want to learn these things from
finding all the combinations
we would not speak until we're 45 just
to do quantifiers cope
my kid has to see to i i went through an
example that
trophy example if you want to figure out
all the examples to not all of them even
go by the rule of thumb
how many examples you need to learn we
have a rule of thumb
you just go by that and do variations on
the trophy
because the trophy could be a phone
could be a laptop right
so we're back to the computational
feasibility versus and
principle kind of question and i agree
with you on the feasibility when people
talk about understanding language in
this kind of in this kind of sense
okay they pose these kind of questions
what does this pronoun refer to
and what object is missing here at this
table
or something like this where what i see
with statistical learning
let's say something really simple a
language model is simply
made to reproduce text that it sees
often
so nowhere in all of wikipedia and
in all the english novels do two people
converse
about the pronoun in the sentence that
came before
the sentence right it's never in a novel
it's like and frank entered the door
and then mary said to frank what did the
in the last sentence of this very novel
refer
to that never happened so so actually
you're making my point that the
information needed
is not in the data not exactly because
what i feel is you
people then try to to ask these neural
network
these kinds of questions that human
would ask to each other what does this
pronoun refer to
but but that's not where i'm coming from
i'm coming from this is real language
use
and if you want to ask a database a
question you better resolve scopes
and you better interpret the pronouns
properly wrong result
and the boss is going to say and my boss
is going to say
screw your system it's giving me the
wrong answer i'm being
i'm no i'm not i'm getting back to this
i'm being very practical
yeah if you want to ignore them one way
to solve a problem is to ignore that it
exists
all right no practical a bit
like my the point to the end would be
something
like let's test these
neural networks by the way that we feed
into
so my hypothesis would be
i accept that the neural network
understands the language
if it can do something useful with it
so if i enter the corner table wants a
beer
and then i ask it to continue the text
and the next sentence is
all right let's get the guy one or all
right let's get the couple another
set of glasses then to me that means the
neural network
understands that there is a person
whether or not in internally does this
whole logic reasoning is a different
question
okay look yeah maybe don't try that
example i tried simpler ones and
you don't want to you don't want to see
the results but look
maybe i'm not making my point sharply
there are things in language that
require require information that
is obviously not in the data that's one
i can i can it's just it's this snk that
i have here it's the semantic structures
and the common
knowledge and i think yeah what you're
talking about is what while it calls
nlp you know natural language processing
fine you can
get some text generate new text or
whatever but
if the data set's missing this s and k a
it's hopeless that
any bertology can learn it and secondly
even if we provided it with
s and maybe some parts of k is it even
computationally feasible that it can you
know
learn all of k it's a lot like
reinforcement learning in that sense a
bit
like it's if if we were to just let a
reinforcement learning algorithm
go on very hard problems we would a bit
make the same argument
all it sees is the input and the reward
and it's supposed to figure out all of
how the world works
just from that it seems like a bit the
same
yeah except there you're just building a
sim a simulator that incorporates s and
k
one way or another you have to have s
and k not necessary if you're doing
something simple like q learning you're
not you're just
building a neural network that
implicitly
does this so my question would be all
right if we know that these
structures and this common knowledge is
missing from let's say statistical
methods today
is there still a place for these
statistical methods what if someone were
to come to you and say
i'm going to build a system that doesn't
have these
rules built in but that has a module
that can generate rules like this on the
fly
and maybe that's how children learn
they're rapidly generating those rules
and now you're getting into something
i'm working on but before
we keep saying rules it's like chomsky
the other is rules and the other no
they're not rules what we have that's
missing are not rules
ironically there are data but different
kinds of data
it's the data we don't say so it's like
data plus data will do the trick
we're trying to do it with one piece of
data which is the
text not the data that we have in our
head so it's not
rules in the end actually neural
networks are rule-based there's a paper
that proves everything is a rule like
kant used to say there's a rule behind
everything otherwise the word will not
survive one day there's
so but what's missing is are not rules
they are
the other data that we have that we
share and that's why we don't say in the
text because we know
we have so if i want to follow shannon's
efficiency for communication i leave it
out because i know
the receiver has that information so
it's data actually
just a quote because i know you're
referring to this quote which is
everything in nature in the inanimate as
well as the animate world happens
according to some rules although we
don't always know them
but you seem to be advocating then that
you do still believe in the data-driven
approach but you think we should have
some kind of augmentation to fill in the
gaps
that's it bingo that's where i'm coming
from the thing is
there are loads of people in the
community doing this already
right because a lot of people would
argue that the fundamental problem in
statistical learning isn't the missing
information problem it's the sample
efficiency problem
and the lack of generalization and
extrapolation
but that's where they're wrong they can
never get to that point without
admitting what the problem with the
empirical methods is they are religious
about symbols and
and admitting there are symbolic
structures let's
call them whatever you want they don't
want to admit one
symbol in the system i can learn
everything jan lacun had a paper which
i'm sure he's ashamed of now he put on
the archive that you can learn
you can learn language from characters
all the way up
come on man come on
iman well kant was not stupid you're not
smarter than him
there's a limit to how far you can go
with your extremism
they don't want to admit one symbol
it's all neural firing they have the
inside of the brain
in their sleep like it's all firing and
wait a minute
who told if that was the case the
difference between our brain and the
chimpanzee
is what is negligible yet a chimpanzee
will take two more million years and
they will not speak
there's something else besides the
firing my friend
animal intelligence have been studied a
long time ago the best they can do
is association they cannot do the
experiment with the monkey
they put a box that if they stepped on
it they would reach the banana
but they put the box in the corner of
the room the monkey almost
went hungry they didn't do one simple
deduction
i need that much height that has that
high if then else
at the end of the day we have a a
structure of meat
up in our head that's based off the same
basic
biology and unless we're going to
believe in souls or mysticism
at the end of the day it it does just
come down to firing
of neurons and some very complex
temporal pattern now here's the thing
neural networks is their frame today
even at the neuron level
are vastly different from what's
actually happening
in the the biological space of the
neurons like
i'm curious at a structural level so it
literally the neuron level
and connectivity what do you think are
some of the missing
features of actual biological neurons
at a structural level versus neurons
that we use
in the sort of neural networks of today
what's missing that enables this
advanced behavior let me just pose
some examples is it the nature of the
connectivity
is it the nature of the non-linear
aspects of the neurons
is it the nature of the temporal aspects
like that neurons can fire over time and
basically do
computation co-processing what there is
the synchronous synchronicity
issue yes temporal thing and there was a
brilliant scientist
years ago actually was my external
examiner on my phd he was at berkeley
who who tried to model variables
if you want like how do i know in
programming if i want to refer to
something here
and that was a genius innovation by
freyja the idea of scope
i have so we have spoke right that's
like
bindings and that's reference and we use
it in language we say it
and i know it's pointing there's like a
reference a pointer actually
so he tried to model that with time with
temporal aspects in neural network that
is amazing work
but i'll get to your answer about what's
missing
but i think what's missing is the
information would pass
it cannot be all numeric and who said
now about the the human uh versus animal
i know that by the way i'm an atheist
proud atheist
a radical atheist so i i am a scientist
to the bone i don't okay
but the difference between us and
animals it actually made my point we're
almost identical biologically
so there's something else obviously
right and if you think about it
it's language and thinking the and that
was discovered years ago
thought and language are if and only if
you can have thought
so language is not just nlp that's the
point i try to make
language is i think we should find
another acronym i came up with one
yesterday
h little u t big u hutu
human thought understanding we're not
this is
this is about thinking we're trying to
we're trying to interpret the thought
behind what you coded for me in english
or chinese
the difference between us and animals is
at some point in the evolution
something happened biologically no
spirit no nothing
that triggered the creation of some
module
and if you look at the history of that i
i really tried to read a lot about it
it happened at the same time when people
started creating two
tools and they're not stupid anymore
they don't try to move iraq
like by bringing two thousand tribes
they found out the lever
and then so thought and language came
together
something happened biologically some
spark
that made us different from other
species and we went
obviously now we can bring an elephant
as big as my apartment
to its cage gladly by a banana so
obviously we're much smarter
we developed something else language
came with that
what is it inside i don't know but your
question is
what do i think is missing in neural net
is that
the information passed from one layer to
the other
although that's not exactly how it
happens in the brain i agree actually in
the brain there's no back propagation
either but
the information passed cannot be all
numeric
why are we saying the information is
just numeric who's that
in the end if it's numeric it's also
symbols
so why the strength of the
firing there's nothing in my mind that
says
we're not passing look our genetic code
is a language
call it anything you don't want to call
c and g symbols
call them i don't know x and call them
anything but we pass
information that information cannot all
be
numeric this comes to the intentionality
we can do with intentions
obviously we pass richer structures than
that
now if you combine that with the
learnability the power of the neural net
is the learnability if you combine
learnability
with richer structures man you're on to
something but you want to fix it on
vectors and numbers
you think you can model the word we were
talking about word embeddings
they cannot do more than similarity
that's their ceiling but why are you
stuck
on i don't want to admit symbols i don't
know how they are manifested inside
so let's agree i'm calling them
something else but the information
passed is much richer than just
a weight they cannot model ever this
cannot model everything that's all my
the question i have about explicit
knowledge like we did in the 1980s is
that it became quite brittle
and the knowledge graphs just kept
growing and growing actually if
we do play the knowledge game and a lot
of people
have different ideas of what knowledge
is and whether there is such a thing as
absolute truth right because in the
enlightenment period we
arrived on the concept of facts but but
tim that's why i wanted to interrupt i
know where you're going
and this is really what makes me
now even on bet terms with the guys
that are still working on that approach
because they're all playing god
doug leonard psych okay you don't want
to see the debates i had with him
he thinks this is how the word is
structured you go to sower he thinks
and they were all playing games and
everybody described their own ontology
and
wrong the structure we have if i
now i'm gonna get into details of what i
found but
the structure we have is universal and
thus
it cannot be created it has to be
discovered
anything that can be created in more
than one way
by by inverse logic it is not different
thus it has to be discovered we have to
pray like archaeologists
discover that damn structure underneath
language
all that they're doing is rubbish they
will never scale they
mccarthy told them you will build
something you will build something that
you won't even understand in five years
and that's where they are now i know
people that work with them and then add
this piece of knowledge maybe it'll get
smarter and
that's rubbish by the way tim the
structure that i found out
is a lot smaller and simpler than
anybody would have thought
which of your papers lays this out i i
stopped publishing on the internal
structure after i won an award and
solved a big problem
best paper award because i'm thinking
about this commercially now really
there's a small actually it's a small
type constraint structure and it's look
at a four year old four-year-old has the
knowledge base of doug glennon
my god a four-year-old can barely walk
but they can speak
fluently the structure they have is much
simpler than we think
i i don't know why it probably has to be
it is
it is actually the entire
ontology is like 2 000 types
something you can code in one day it's
what is that structure and
when you have a mismatch and typing in
the text how do you do type unification
to discover
what was not said that's the trick
look language cannot be that difficult
proof three year olds
okay three-year-olds don't have domain
knowledge they don't have the knowledge
base that granite is trying to build
and he's acting like god first we have
things and then we have abstract things
who told you now you're asking me how do
you discover that structure
how do you discover what is underneath
you have a theory called language
reverse engineer it do you do you allow
for
for the possibility that these types
and even the structure that connects the
types
are themselves represented
in a distributed way let's say in a
vector numerical way
exactly i'll send you a picture can i
share something
that's you hit it there's the data level
i'm not ignoring there's a data level
but there's a lot
above tim and yannick this is completely
in line with
the discussions we've been having in the
image recognition space of look if you
just add a little bit of structure
add a little bit of common knowledge
equivariance
and variances somehow that was built
into this processing
you could be so much more efficient with
your degrees of freedom
and a lot more successful yeah because
it could do this spatial reasoning
against that
it always comes across that the
kind of transformations we can think
about as humans just don't cut it for
the real world at least in vision like
people say
it should be translation invariant like
really
yeah it cuts it very well that's why we
survived that's why our species exist
it works really well in the real world
i know but vision seems to be harder
because language is language whereas
vision it
if you take it on a photo photograph on
a camera you've got this weird spherical
manifold and it's not really a
representation of
things as they exist in the real world i
think they're very different i can't say
which one is harder is mixed integer
optimization harder than
continuous it depends on a lot of
factors right non-linear is it
is it brittle how many dimensions etc so
i don't know which is harder but they're
definitely very different
i think if you go beyond just image
recognition into scene analysis then you
will
encounter the same problem as language
and that type structure will also help
you because you know what
constrains what and so here's the thing
we have data and we have information and
we have knowledge forget the symbols i
know you don't like symbols but
right at the bottom level
and remember i was talking about
ontological concepts
things like and they don't have to be
physical by the way ontological concept
concepts that are that just are they
happen
or i see them or whatever or i
experienced them
but i saw someone going like this we
called it dancing whatever it is
so these are the things right and these
come from
sensory inputs signals that's where the
neural network will give these things a
meaning
these type judgments it will tell me
what a human is
it will tell me what a dancing is
because so so i get these types
that's where i built my ontological
structure
now these things are type judgments okay
i walk around like a four-year-old i see
a human i see a dancing
sometimes i might use my dad and say
what is this and he tells me that's a
raven okay whatever
but that's the data level where neural
nets are
the only not they are good for it
they're the only alternative
because i need to make a pattern and
call it something that's where neural
networks are powerful
then we go to information now these
types
that's where our structure has this
richness so now i know that
articulate is something that generally
speaking makes sense of a human and by
the way there's polymorphism here if
uh imminent event that means any event
type
also goes there so i can say imminent
trip
eminent seminar whatever and then
there's the third level where i start
making statements and
so that's analogous to
first order and second order logic isn't
it at some points like
types and then qualification over types
or
quantification over types it is related
to logic but believe it or not
the final output has nothing to do with
the logic
all i know is that static typing helps
programming significantly
don't know don't tell the anecdotal
yeah i'm sorry i got into python
recently and i love it but i hate
that it's not type me too yeah i think
wallet would appreciate that
in my opinion the types are like
violence if they don't solve your
problem
it's because you're not using enough of
them but then you've just externalized
what you want to solve into the type
system then you're essentially just
programming
in the type system and the type system
itself isn't type
checked right like i can build a union
of any two types
yeah so if i have a type system that
completely solves my problem i've just
programmed my algorithm in the language
of the type system which itself has no
type system so i
again they're no no at all
we're slightly derailing this yeah
you can make a type system or the type
checking the final representation
has to be language agnostic otherwise
you're doing something wrong
so if i say john knows that sofia wants
to be famous
the thought underneath that whether i
say it in french or dutch or german or
english or whatever
the thought behind it should be language
agnostic
so it's like a knowledge graph but the
trick is how do we go from that
to that knowledge graph which has no
predicates whatsoever it's not law
it's there are some primitive relations
like there's the notion of equality
and these relations are really cognitive
relations that every human being can
relate to
we can all relate to this equals this or
this is a part of this
now are you saying this set was
empirically discovered
or this is back to human constructed
this is the way the world is
no it was reverse engineered from
language itself like you want to
discover how language works
take it backwards there's a and this is
not entirely my idea
many people said to understand human
communication
we have to reverse engineer language
itself it's the best
it's the best model of our internal
mental ease but those were examples from
that process
from a reverse engineering right not
from an on high this is the way i think
the world is
okay no i reduced it to primitive types
that
would be available like any time that
your internal representation has
subject and object and verb and i mean
come on
there are languages that don't have that
structure if your internal rep
cannot reduce your internal
representation into language agnostic
representation
you're still not there so i kept pushing
it to this raw
stuff and then the types came up and i
discovered there's a logical type
that's what i meant by teacher is
reducible
teacher is just an agent agent is
universally cognitively universal i know
there's an actor in an activity
that's okay that's acceptable so teacher
is just an
agent and something we see and we call
teaching you have to reduce it all to
internal
stuff that we all have otherwise you're
doing symbolic stuff so that's why
the symbolic camp also doesn't like what
i'm doing so i
i'm stuck in between i'm like guys
you have the data level covered that
where the signals come from
but you guys everything you have in your
system is
simple defined in terms of symbol just
like mr miyagi said if you walk the left
side of the street
you're okay if you walk the right side
you're okay if you walk in the middle
squish just like grape so what goes a
bit not against that but
in the last especially the last few
years
we've actually seen as you say the the
opposite trend
and the matter of fact is that
as we take out rules from these systems
they get better we take more and more
and now the best systems we have
is just a very agnostic 24 100 layers
transformer
and right my last word on rules is i did
the same and the thing got better
yeah i took rules out it's not about
rules i don't i really have rules in
myself
there's structure this but still the
structure you impose
in a 50 layer transformer is so minimal
and as we take out structure but just
make
it bigger it gets better right
because on that we're in the blank slate
the tabarossa paradigm
and transformers are a super
generalization even of
fully connected neural networks and why
does such a blank slate paradigm work so
well
does it work so well and well it does
because this is the thing there are so
many ways we can constrain
we could put priors in to constrain
these things but the most
general purpose models work best
tim as far as language and these systems
they really like ufos you hear about
them you never see them every time i try
one of them
it doesn't know i don't want to be
it's too early to speak french
there's no we keep saying that they're
doing well where
come on you're not allowed to use them
anymore they're not going to give you
access they're not going to give you
access to them the difference between
gpt3 and gp2 is not that great
and if you use what's available they're
a joke alan
i tried the ai too even it's they're
nowhere near
anything with all understanding come on
yeah this is it so this is the example
you gave in one of your articles which
is that
the premise on entailment uh a house is
bigger than a chair
a hypothesis chairs fit inside a house
and we're getting an entailment of 45.7
which in a contradiction of 52.1 it's
pretty bad
it's not as bad as whatever the other
one was but this still is terrible
it's pretty bad although it's not as bad
as the one i think actually tim can you
stay there
and and say chairs fit inside your home
inside a home yeah they should get there
okay this would be interesting
word embedding will do that home oh it's
quite similar
because this was the other question i
wanted to ask you a wallet though
because i think you you
implied that because there isn't a type
system
inside in this paradigm of deep learning
that it would think of home and house as
being completely
separate but i think because there's a
statistical interpolation between the
word vectors i think it
would infill right word embeddings will
do the job here home and house will be
quite similar
but but if you say a dwelling maybe now
you're way off and you're already ready
let's try a mousetrap see what happens
with the mousetrap
and you're already in the 52
contradiction for god's sake this is
beyond a three-year-old
ah now so it likes dwelling let's put
any two sentences
with dwelling matchbox like at the end
yeah yeah i've done that anytime i've
done that yeah and it really
actually put okay tim is bigger than a
dwelling
no oh 44 chance of that
come on so that's partially true you
know
here is a problem that i have with these
kinds of assessment right
is that they're very constructed and
they don't tell us much about
how these models or do these models
understand language because
naturally we know this the best example
from this is
visual question answering so you get a
picture and then you get a question
along with it
and it the question would be something
like what's the ground covered with
and i don't have to show you the picture
like the answer is snow
like just from language that's going to
be the answer and i feel a lot of these
like these kind of super glue tasks are
there are so many shortcuts and it's not
really about
how what do you think that's another
problem i have this glue and they keep
breaking records and
out comes another paper and chop more
trees and publish
and these days you have someone has 12
papers in a conference
like man i mean john mccarthy had 12
papers all his life
so basically it's another table at the
end that says
i got 1.01
more accurate than jim and that's a
paper so
and these glue tests if you look at them
actually they were at
above 90 accuracy six years ago
isn't it time to say we're perfect i
mean stop playing this game you create a
data set
that suits you well and you optimize it
for your code and
it's a game right it's a game the
winograd schema challenge is decent i
wrote the paper to improve it further
it depends where you want to test but
for language understanding
all these glue benchmarks are a joke
these are for
tech companies to play games with each
other facebook and microsoft and
google this winograd schema challenge i
just looked at this paper describing it
and there were
108 pronoun disambiguation problems and
89 winograd schemers
and so the pronoun disambiguation i
think that's the one where you gave an
example of
the trophy fit in the suitcase because
it was too big or too small and you want
to resolve
yeah by the way my opinion is it's a
decent test but it's not enough
but that's i wrote about that okay but
there's only 108 of them and of course
it was designed to be google proof
because at some point
you can just go on the internet and
search for these things but that doesn't
this is part of the super glue challenge
isn't it 108
tests that just doesn't seem no that
doesn't seem like a good test to me
no the on the glue benchmark again
they created their own set of the
winograd and they said if we can do that
we've done the winograds
that's not the point of the winograd
schema the winograd schema is
open-ended i give you a sentence and it
has a reference in it
and and the reference has at least two
choices so you have to think
make a decision and so they created
their own set
and it's obviously optimized for that
and they say they have ninety percent
act
what if you have ninety percent accuracy
i'd like to buy that system
you've won the touring award it's a joke
it's a joke
i i can beat those systems with one
example
there's look it there's a lot of hype
and it's too
academia has become unfortunate when you
when we used to go to hki or
aaai my god i was afraid to meet anyone
because i'm so idiotic about ai
now they go and they present 15 papers
and it's like
what the you know einstein
albert einstein didn't publish 15 papers
i always used to say oh the great thing
about deep learning
is that 15 years ago you had to have
specialized knowledge about vision or
language processing you actually needed
to know something about the sub-domain
whereas now all you need to know is how
to build neural networks
you don't need to understand anything at
all
yeah but is that the good or the bad it
used to be that in data analysis we
thought that
garbage in was garbage out and all that
deep learning has changed is that
garbage in is garbage out with a high
degree of confidence
it's like getting papers out yeah it's
like you have people that
they don't know they don't know anything
and they can write a bunch of code and
there's this sort of mathematical
passport type psychology that goes
around where if it's complicated enough
and i put enough math in there
even if it's just trash nobody can
question it now it's and if we found
something
some hack that works really well people
go back in time and try and justify it
mathematically even though they they
didn't have any basis for doing it
in the first place batch norm for
example all the papers written on why it
works why it doesn't work
et cetera so i think it's a bad thing in
a lot of ways
a group of people at mit published a
paper where they analyzed
something like 2000 papers and they said
we have bad news we could not reproduce
any results
probably they were able to reproduce a
small fraction and they said those that
we were able to reproduce
they we could have done the same
accuracy with good old-fashioned
decision trees
you should go over to allen nlp and ask
it if batch norm works
like does matter so to be fair it's easy
to complain and it's easy to complain
about a field and so on and of course if
you put more math in a paper and so on
but it's not the people doing neural
networks have
zero knowledge of the domain when
vaswani introduced this new language
model that predicts the next word
you you don't need to you don't need to
know anything about language whatsoever
you're just producing the most general
blank slate deep learning model to
predict the next word
sure but they're it doesn't it doesn't
mean that
they aren't still experts at that
it's to see what exactly you're doing
and and how you're doing it
and the internals you i think you still
need a bit
of of expertise maybe not in linguistics
but still in like just the processing of
language to have a feeling for that
i don't believe that these are absolute
newcomers like yeah but
i i i i agree and disagree yannick i
agree with you they must have something
else right it's not
but i work in the field i was around ml
people
which now means nlp like wait a minute
nlp
is not ml and nlu is not an lp and it's
not ml
those young kids who put on their
linkedin ml
nlp ai
and i work with them on chat bots and
yeah
internet of things crypto everything and
blockchain
blockchain and we used to be afraid to
say i know nlp
alone language understanding that's a
huge
so anyways these guys i talk to them
they're working on chatbots with me and
they're doing dialogue system
they have no idea what language it is
you know what language for them is
tokenizing stemming it's text
yeah and if you're stemming still
and if you and if you if you ask if if
you mention
any name that work in language they say
huh
they think you're talking about monica
lewinsky or something
in your article here you actually have
some technical
descriptions of concepts in language
like this one
metonymy right if you ask any
anyone who's got nlp deep learning on
their linkedin profile what that means
no no no one's going to know the answer
forget it forget
oh i'm talking about even i'm talking
about questions that are much simpler
than that
for god it took them a while to know
about lexical ambiguity oh words have
different meanings
and we call that lexical ambiguity okay
that was an
achievement metonymy is way above the
sky
reference resolution why is that a
problem
and one cool guy said we solve reference
resolution by actually ignoring pronouns
stop words
yeah but the thing is though like
in vision the reason why cnns are now
ubiquitous is because they produce
features that are better than
any handcrafted features all of these
specialists that were super
into vision they basically just got
wiped away so why is language so
different
okay let's start from the beginning yeah
no
language is different look i is it
here's the issue with language and
actually it's not just language
if everything is learnable i can
disprove that everything is learnable in
in
in less than a minute if things are
learnable
people have different experiences
different observations that means
they could in theory learn different
things there are so many actually the
vast amount
of stuff that makes sense in the world
we cannot disagree on if we disagree on
they call them
or they have a name for us they say
stupid so
since there is so much that we cannot
disagree on
that stuff has not been learned because
if it
was learned we would learn it
differently for example
this is basic science there's common
sense in science too you know
so one thing is if x is larger than y
and y is larger than z larger
obeys the transited relation it's not up
to you
it's not up to me it's not up to dave
it's not
up to ellen musk greater than is a
transitive relation and we know it by
the age of two or three
if i tell my kid hey buddy can you put
the ball in
in the back papa it's much bigger
bigger doesn't fit end of story so
if you want to if things are learned we
could learn them
differently because we have different
experiences that's not the case
i don't know when scientists forgot
common sense
look at the word we disagree on very few
things
the way the word works physically
logically
chemically is not up to you or to me
there's an agreement otherwise you're
called stupid or doesn't know science
there's very little disagreement in in
the word we live in
oh yeah we disagree on what we think of
donald trump but
and on crucial things we don't disagree
because there are facts in this world
and these facts
are undisputable that means they're not
learnable they're not susceptible to
data now come on every computer
scientist should read philosophy
philosophers can teach us a lot
they don't produce anything that makes
sense but at least they tell us you're
going the wrong way
my question from before was what would
your advice be
on how should we evaluate language
systems let's say
we're really trying to come up with
these
these kind of nlu system not nlp but nlu
systems language understanding what
would be a good
set of principles maybe or even a test
i'm writing something on that actually i
wrote
some of it in a paper that appeared a
year ago but
i'm trying to formalize this remember
the bit about
and that was the gist of our discussion
as to what's unique about nlu
and that there's a lot of information we
don't convey because i assume you have
it
you call it the common background
knowledge the test should be
can you uncover that information then
you're doing understanding
so the test that i have the undergrad
schema is
one example of that because it's very
specific to reference resolution
you need to extract text that is not
there to resolve the reference
but this phenomena and tim was listing
those things actually he was
on that screen there are ten big
problems in language computational
linguals give them labels like
metonymy lexical ambiguity metaphor
all these big problems in language and
they're all a manifestation of the
missing text
so basically it's a generalization of
the winograd schema
can you uncover that the information
that is obviously needed
to understand this but it's not
explicitly in the text
then that then you have an ai system you
mean
i want to have all of this in a
knowledge store and i want to link it
or account for it somehow i came up with
a way to to actually account for it
now you might hey it will open my god
some people might say this is something
that i
can also learn from somewhere i don't
know but you have to account for that
because our goal is what you need that
missing text to figure out what is
really being said
can you find it what approach you have
hey but would you accept a system that
says
i i can't link anything but i can give
you
20 sentences that can follow the
sentence you give me and that all
make it clear that i use the
words in their proper like that i have
properly resolved a reference or i've
properly
imputed the missing text otherwise i
couldn't continue
the text as such okay yeah that falls
under you
you manage to account for the missing
information but but basically
the language understanding problem the
you
and that makes it different from the nlp
is finding that stuff that we take for
granted because i know you know it
so that's the real test okay a system is
thinking
if it can uncover what i know i should
know
to understand this so what if that
there's a particular bar
in australia and when they say the
corner table wants another beer
they are referring to just the corner
table as if it was an animal
object and had sentience
it could happen which means want
want in that environment doesn't expect
a type that is person only
it expects types that are more general
expects anything
doesn't that mean then that our
knowledge graph will just grow
if the knowledge graph is constructed in
that relative way so it means something
different in australia
doesn't that complicate things
significantly by generalizing on the
type
everything becomes different so
basically if it's not specifically
person
it could be entity and all of a sudden
you generalize it to anything you want
there's power and type systems type
structures allow
more flexibility than we think so for
them
want is not too restrictive to person
tables can want something okay that's
fine
but in the world of object-oriented
programming we used to have a type
inheritance hierarchy as well and people
abused it massively it produced some of
the most horrible code in the world
and that's why we had the concept of
interfaces and composability so
do you think that would be a logical
extension of what you're suggesting
exactly and i used to argue against
multiple inheritance every time multiple
inheritance
you're doing something wrong nothing is
two things
everything is a thing so look the
ontology i have is actually strictly
binary
you're either this or this you cannot be
uh you're either a bird
or a cow i mean and if you're hybrid
then it's a different type all together
there is no multiple inheritance
otherwise you have something wrong
definitely
yeah we created interfaces because of
multiple inheritance and people started
saying
yeah and you know why they did multiple
enhancements of the reuse of code
okay so i make it the subtype of this so
that i can reuse also the functions that
are here
but that's called bad software
engineering i used to teach that and
man you don't subtype just to reuse code
that means your model is wrong
right so you do you can do it in another
way by containment and delegation
but the point is the there's a system
underneath language
it's not an accident that we all
understand each other
the the one of the most things that
really annoy me when people say that
know a little about language this but
language is ambiguous of course it's
ambiguous
even but it's ambigu but ambiguity
can be dealt with i know that initially
i start with something that could mean
20 things
but obviously we don't stop each other
on every time we're talking and say hey
wait a minute what do you mean by that
what do you mean by we don't
we understand each other very nicely and
i go to the zoo and i see a
four-year-old girl and i talk with her
for three hours
and i never stop her to say what do you
mean we understand
each other language is ambiguous in the
sense that
we compress things and then we try to
uncompress them
until the picture is clear so in the in
the beginning
it has many possibilities but it's not
ambiguous in the sense we don't
understand each other no we do
so even ambiguity has has
even type ambiguous at some point i have
a very generic type
all i know is that this this is an
entity
so if i say sarah or not sarah
is a common female name let's say uh
shiva
right or java as a programming language
an island
is the name of someone i know someone
called java so if i say
java up to this point it's ambiguous but
if i say
java just told me uh blah blah blah blah
java as a human islands don't say
anything
so unless it's metonymy like the new
york times said blah blah blah
and it's not the new york fans it's
editors at the new york times
but language is more systematic than we
think look
at three-year-olds that's all i'm gonna
say you can talk with them forever
and they know what you're saying they
don't have specialized knowledge
they can barely open the door for god's
sake and they don't stop you all the
time and say dad what do you mean what
do you mean they know and actually they
so language i believe
what kant says everything can be
described by some
system yeah and what montague trivially
then infer
which is language is a formal language
it's just that we didn't we haven't
figured out
the compiler of that damn language
right there's a compiler for natural
language
in our head that compiles natural
type checking and all it does everything
according to
rules we agreed on obviously but we
haven't figured it out
so if we did build this global ontology
because i've
been in software engineering for about
20 years and a lot of teams of software
engineers really struggle to come up
with
an entity structure just for a basic
trading application
and we're talking about building a
global ontology if such an ontology
could exist
because i know you have the concept of
ontological types and logical concepts
so how big do you think this would be
and is it one of these things where
there would be a kind of fragmentation
so sometimes you would need to split one
concept up into
several smaller ones just to have the
fidelity to capture the the knowledge
no first of all size wise i told you'll
be surprised
how you can cover all natural languages
not language because in the end these
are concepts that are underneath
all languages of course you might come
up with new concepts every now and then
so laptop
didn't exist before but feud a couple of
decades ago
actually the structure is quite small
the trick is finding out what that
structure is
and the relationship between these
different types
and here's another one that gave me a
big hint i was
obviously i was helped by many brilliant
people that i took from each some smart
idea and i found out something
one of them is jerry fodor who said in a
footnote actually
in a book that i'm still trying to
understand he wrote a short book
a few years before he died called
concept the subtitle is where cognitive
science went wrong
very heavy stuff metaphysics there's
computability in it
anywhere from alan turing to what's
computable and
the mind and neural networks and he's a
big critic of that paradigm by the way
but in a footnote where he's describing
the
formal meaning of ontology not ontology
as we use
it now like taxonomy basically or the
graph knowledge graphs rdf these are
ontologies
genuine oncologists but he's referring
to ontology as
in what exists what's out there and how
are they related
the old metaphysical meaning of ontology
and in a footnote
that it's unbelievable how much
information it gave me when i put it was
something else i read
he says every concept is
locked or owned by a word in the
language
otherwise it wouldn't exist in other
words actually
yannick asked me before what's the
criteria what do you how do you know
this is logical
this is the criteria and voters footnote
if a concept doesn't own at least one
word in the language
it's his it's it's in other words
if you're not an ontological concept
unless you own at least an adjective or
a property that's
uniquely yours it was a footnote
and then because of all the other stuff
i was reading i was like
holy crap that's what it is so in other
words
f x if i know what x
is what type of object x is because of
some word
some unique word told me x is a human
done and so that makes
in the ontology going back to the
science that makes a laptop
and uh and an ipad
really ontologically the same because
there's no word that i can uniquely use
for people think when i'm talking about
this anthology that i'm talking about
all the concepts in the world no
the rest are instances so for example
there's no word in english that i can
use on a bmw that i cannot use on
we're talking used in the sense that
it's sensible to
to use on or it makes sense not that
it's true or false i don't care
so sensibly there's no word that i can
use sensibly on honda's and not bmws
which means all these things there goes
three thousand concepts they're really
one ontological type
car so it's much smaller than you might
think them it's
you're not building an enterprise
data you know what i'm saying data
warehouse where you have to cover every
entity and every person no
you're building ontological types that
cover each one of them two hundred
thousand yeah well
so it's really two thousand times each
times 200 times
we're talking about billions but the
ontological types that are needed for
language
are are a lot less than people would
think
so it's actually surprisingly
by the sounds of it a lot of people
would be surprised by that and you've
said previously that data-driven
mechanisms can only detect and infer and
recognize
ontological types but not these logical
concepts which are the majority of
objects in human thought but anyway just
to close out but you've mentioned
jeremy four-door and also in your
influences you've listed people like
emanuel canton
richard montagu and jerry hobbs as well
actually but
if people are interested in seriously
learning about natural language
understanding
having listened to this conversation
where would you point them to
actually a friend of mine who works at
amazon just asked me to give him a list
because he said i don't know anything
about nlu obviously it depends
where you want to start i would start
with the
the cognitive stuff where what the hell
is language and its relation to the mind
and
before i get into specific models and
because then you'll find your way but
the relationship between mind and
language and thought there are
some great stuff about that really tells
you that language
is a different beast okay language is
really about the mind
it's about thoughts the only reason we
came up with language is we were like so
frustrated i want to convey thoughts
so we it's about communicating our
thoughts
and that was the before we had languages
like uh
scribbling on rocks and whatever to
express ourselves
but then somehow there was some spark
that came up with this
unbelievable module we call now language
but
so language if you want to get into it
as
the ai side of language not the text
processing
which is a noble cause and and it
provides practical applications and
i'm all with that if you want to get
really into what language is
and how it relates to the mind and thus
ai
i would start with language and
cognitive science
people like jerry foto people like
george lakoff
people like blackoff had a brilliant
idea he tried to relate language
to the physical world like in language
has to be embodied like metaphors
he believes everything was a metaphor we
say
we're reaching a dead end and it's the
metaphor it's the cognitive schema of
a path and we're trying to go somewhere
and we're basing this metaphor on a
physical schema of
we were going somewhere but we were
reaching a dead end physically
like all of our language you can map it
metaphorically to stuff read that stuff
and it tells you language is not just
characters
start with that then you can go to
specific
approaches okay formal semantics versus
cognitive linguistics there are
paradigms in this
space also there are chomsky but that
family
is not consistent at all the quan
beats the crap of chomsky beats the crap
of and they're all in the same camp
believe me there was there were battles
and jerry forder beats everybody
so that camp there are so many also
approaches and paradigms and
the role of syntax the role of semantics
is it all just knowledge is it
a hybrid there's so much there
but at least to appreciate that language
is not it's not accidental that alan
turing thought of
language as the test for intelligence he
didn't choose pattern recognition he
didn't even choose game playing i
mentioned that in my post
because games as big as they are they're
finite so if you give me enough compute
power
i'll screw it because i'll compute every
possibility and i'll have a score for
every path
you're dead so it's a fighter there are
an
absolutely humongous number of
permutations of board
positions and they did this self-play
yeah so they were brute force
learning but clearly they they didn't
even touch
the search space didn't even touch the
the possible board positions
but they still managed to create a kind
of convex hole and statistically
interpolate between various different
board patterns and it worked quite well
so why could
something similar not work for language
but actually if you look at the details
of
the they didn't report what they
actually did they
cheated they used the a-star
optimization algorithm on the
graph-based optimization and they used
they used monte carlo simulation to
simulate so many games okay and then
all these games there were yes it was
unsupervised in the sense that the game
the system played with itself
and it learned that when i win
these are the things that i should keep
and okay there's brilliant learning
going on here
my point was the game is
finite it doesn't matter how big the
space is so basically
with enough compute power we were able
to go
in depth more than a human then of
course we're going to win
all that happened look there's a nice
paper that explains that
i can win with you and and card game
they have a nice example
basically it's all about increasing my
probability
so if i look at more possible cases and
observations than you
my probability is higher than yours then
in the end i'm gonna win
it's a very decidable thing it just
happened that we didn't have the compute
power chess is large enough go
is like magnitudes but with enough
compute power i
i reached a point where my probability
of running now is like
99 2.1 i actually in language
that's why these schema attacks are good
because
here's an example a teenager shot a
policeman and he immediately fell down
most likely it's the policeman if you
ask everybody that fell down
x shot y falls down but
actually both possibilities are even
plausible
intelligence is about picking out
if there are no plus if there's no
multiple possibility
there's no intelligence going on if i
say john gave mary the book and he was
happy to do so
there's only one possible chance for he
in the discourse and that's john
no intelligence no thinking needed
that's the extreme
but just on on that though i think a lot
of people um in this camp
think of intelligence as being about
reasoning and
deduction and it's reason
dispatches with learning and
generalization
i i think in this conception the
knowledge is explicitly
captured and doesn't change the
knowledge here is
that both the teenager might have fell
down
it could happen and the policeman but
one is more plausible than the other
there's plausibility there's possibility
and there's the probability the
probability is bigger than zero suppose
could happen
one is more possible than the other but
one is more plausible than the other
and plausibility has to do with the word
we live in common sense
if i have a language model and the next
sentence
i give you that's what i was saying
before like i give you
the next sentence one is and the
teenager
ran away the second one is so the
teenager called 9-1-1
the third is and so on which all point
to the fact
that this wasn't possible if it was the
teenager who fell down it was actually
the police officer
wouldn't that be wouldn't would you
accept that
as the system has disambiguated
okay it's it's more than a disambiguate
it understood
okay okay actually the flip side of that
are used in this example
a teenager shot a policeman and he
immediately ran away
now ran away most likely it's the
teenager you try to run away from being
captured blah blah blah
but it could be that policeman ran away
to escape further injuries
in the world of possibilities both are
possible
in the world we live in one is more
plausible so if you can capture that
anyway then you're doing then you're
doing understanding
your reasoning right i'm not uh
whatever model explains that what we do
in language so quickly
right now my so far obviously and
all my work i don't believe that
information
is in data actually that's probably the
gist of where i'm coming from
i don't believe that information is in
the data itself
there there's another structure that
powers and constrains these degrees of
freedom
that are all over the place there's a
constraining system
inside kids show us this
the adjective ordering restriction that
we don't have rules for it we don't
teach kids to do it and it's universal
tells us there's some constraining
system
specific to language yeah and that was
the example so jane was wearing a
beautiful red dress
and no one would ever say a red
beautiful dress
no and they don't know why it there's a
type system doing all that
so there's a lot of evidence that tells
us there's something that can strain all
these possibilities it cannot be
that we have to see examples i i do the
competition
the combinatorics for one of them it
cannot be that a child has to see 40
million examples
to resolve a reference there's they
would not speak before they're like 45.
there's a there's some language module
right
yeah it gets bootstrapped with few
examples maybe it get
it comes to life with few examples but
if you think about it
with kids it's all or nothing at some
point they can't
say a meaningful word and at some point
forget it it's so it's like uh it's like
those couple of years
the first two years or three they're
trying to discover the common sense
word more so than language and once they
got that the language
module is there already but it needs
that understanding of how things
what makes sense so it's because as soon
as they get it
you can't stop them it's not incremental
at all
i had three kids and i experimented with
them
no i i just observed them to write
papers but i
so they once they hit that threshold
once their system is bootstrapped enough
forget it you can't stop them so it's
not this
incremental learning come on no way
or or i guess if you wanna
i'm not extremist about any approach i'm
just against the extremist on the other
side believe me
i'm just seeing so much ridiculous stuff
being said
and i'm like that's when i started the
blog and i'm like
guys everything i'm hearing is rubbish
no
come on you don't you've never been in
this space
you know you've never been in the
language understanding space
let me show you some phenomena there's
something called intention
they have no clue what i'm talking about
i say intention they always have it with
the t
not the s they don't believe that word
exists actually microsoft word annoys me
it's not even in the microsoft word
dictionary i keep adding
it i keep adding it to the dictionary
there's an intention with an s
i give you and in language it's the norm
not the exception
in language we refer to objects
intentionally not
extension we don't refer to their final
value which is just one attribute
we refer to them intentionally as a
concept
that has tons of attributes so
if i say person i say xanadu
i have an example and i have it in the
post like i if i
say gonna do quit graduate school then
immediately a three-year-old knows
xanadu is a human being she
or he is alive because you can't be dead
in graduate school there's a ton of
things now i can write about xanadu
she's at least i don't know 20 i don't
see a 12 year old
regularly in grad school and just by
saying xanadu quit graduate school
i can write tons of properties and i can
write
like a three-page description of them
but even with that though knowledge is
becoming quite relative because
your inferences there were based on the
fact that
people in the western world maybe go to
university
at a certain age could there be a world
where
because i suppose where you're going
with this is that right it all comes
down to reasoning under uncertainty
given explicit knowledge exactly and
it's all about possibility there's no
zero or one
people think i'm against statistics or
i'm not against anything
all i'm saying is it's a very complex
process man and it's about
that it is all about degrees of
belief so for example that's where
logicians actually work a lot about
possible words
right so in the world we live and people
don't fly
but in a superman world i have to
interpret things differently completely
what makes sense or in a religious
community and i had to do that when i
had to go
forcefully with my ex to the church so i
used to and i in that world i had to
accept things
that don't make sense to me but in the
word of religion they do make sense so
there's this idea of possible words
semantics and it's
you jump from one
discourse a one word we call it universe
of discourse
to another and you do context switching
there are complex models for that but
in the end in a certain community in a
certain place
where we're all sharing the
the experience that we have there's
usually agreement on that
and that's why we leave it out from the
text because i believe the rest
so language is a complex beast it's and
that and the challenge in language
understanding is figuring out
how to decode what you told me
given what you assumed i know
it's interesting that you use the word
discourse because that's exactly the
same word as the
french philosophers like uh foucault
but anyway
dr walid sabha it's been an absolute
pleasure it's been an honor actually
thank you so much for coming on the show
and
talking with us this evening this was
beautiful this was great thank you guys
thank you
this was great awesome